the shooting appears to have happened
despite some advanced warning it turns
out five months ago the FBI was tipped
off in a way that a YouTube commenter
was discussing his intent to be a
professional school shooter and how did
the FBI respond they responded pretty
immediately they had a field agent
contact me and meet me in my office the
very next morning and unfortunately I
wasn't able to provide them with much
when you gave them the users name right
which is the same exact name cuter I'm
sure had more time and effort then put
in to finding out who the username
belongs to if that's even possible I
don't know how many Nicholas cruises
there are on YouTube but they may would
have been able to find out who this
person was as you heard the FBI was not
able to identify crews in 2017 the FBI
received information about a comment
made on a YouTube channel the complan
comments simply said I'm going to be a
professional school shooter no other
information was included with that
comment which would indicate a time
location or the true identity of the
person who made the comment the FBI
conducted database reviews checks but
was then it was unable to further
identify the person who actually made
the comment on house codes and former
FBI assistant director here in
Washington he joins us st. Ron thanks
for coming up my pleasure
what happened here do you think you know
I think that at first blush I think the
FBI worked within its guidelines the FBI
is bound by a document it's about this
thick it's known as the dialogue they
take that Bible very seriously and it's
really a document that's meant to limit
the the power of the FBI keep them from
excess and that guides when the
circumstances in which they can open a
case the techniques that they can use in
pursuing a case very often when they
must close a case we've heard that
conversation with some terrorism cases
that have been closed and then somebody
strikes we saw it in Boston in other
places around the country that document
is intended to protect the organization
is it intended to protect you and I from
FBI excesses so in this specific case
how how did that prevent the FBI from
moving well I suspect what happened here
is as is they're working within their
guidelines there's a couple levels of
cases that they can work the the lowest
level of that is essentially it's called
an assessment I have very little
information to start I do not have
enough predication to start a
preliminary inquiry or a full
investigation and use all the FBI's
tools I have very little the guidance of
the diode also does this the FBI is a
federal investigative agency its focuses
on the federal law that diag is pointing
them towards federal crimes and national
security threats and here on its face
you may have neither of those two things
you have some words that that some would
say that's freedom of speech right I'm
not threatening somebody directly I'm
just throwing up some hate supposition
on the internet and walking away from it
stirring people up that's a that's a
totally fair point I wonder we've been
pretty tough on the FBI recently on this
show and I think in a way that's
warranted but I also think in cases like
this are we vesting too much confidence
in all of our law enforcement that they
can prevent people bent on mass murder
from committing and that seems like a
lot to ask well that is a lot to ask
first I think law enforcement absolutely
has to try to connect up yeah and here I
do think the FBI probably owes us a
little bit more clarity on what steps
they took however if I don't like
something you say on this show and I'm
sitting at the FBI and you write
critical of them recently they don't get
to start a case on Tucker that's right
and start following him because one of
those things of an authorized purpose is
it can't be for protected First
Amendment rights no I'm sorry you and
minute ago reference diag just their
diet right diag what can you just tell
us what that's is that an acronym what
is it is the is the FBI's investigative
an operational guide
okay so it's the handbook it's it's the
handbook it's this thick all right
everyone is tested on it they here they
get lectures on it from internal legal
teams they adhere to that it's audited
their conduct is audited there's
somebody looking over their shoulder to
say you did this right or you were
outside of the bounds on this and First
Amendment protected speech is one of
those key areas that the dialog talks
about repeatedly and so they may have
had an authorized purpose to start an
assessment but they can use very few
tools and what what rob Lasky referred
to right there is open source they can
do database checks right other
government agency database checks or
open source and that's about it this is
not the type of case where you're going
to go to the US Attorney's Office and
say give me a stack of subpoenas I'm
gonna start you so if somebody says I
may become a professional school shooter
who knows what it means but if he said
I'm gonna shoot up this school on this
date presumably now you have a better
starting point right but here if I'm
listening to those words and I've had
this experience one of my first
questions is is on its face is this
prosecutable well right US Attorney's
office take this the answer is no no it
is no yeah it's a shame Ron thank you
for that